He just basically only finds mega crits.
Right.
So it's like, it's safe for Chapman, right?
Like Chapman has 20 bucks a year and makes more than all of everyone else.
This guy's average payout is like, you know, 15 grand.
That's part of hacking when you can just, you know, critical thing.
Right.
Okay. Look, guys, you know, I'm a little bit picky about sponsors for this podcast, right?
And this next sponsor, I personally went and sought out myself.
So hang tight.
Listen for a second.
Let me tell you about them.
Okay.
This is the Adobe bug bounty program.
And they are one of the best bug bounty programs out there.
A ton of hackers love their program and really respect it.
And their brand we all know and love, right?
Who hasn't used an Adobe product over the years?
They're a public program.
So you can hack on it with your friends super easily.
The bounties are great.
And guys, the scope is unmatched.
They've got wildcard domains.
They've got massive primary apps like Adobe Photoshop and Lightroom.
They've got open source software like Magento, aka Adobe Commerce.
They've got executables like ColdFusion.
If you're looking to do some of that, like Shubs-esque zero-day research
on architectural related stuff.
They've got mobile apps like Adobe Reader and Photoshop Mobile.
It is a freaking treasure trove of scope, you guys.
And like we always say in the pod, you should hack on targets that have live hacking events
if you want to get invited to live hacking events, right?
And Adobe has been in the Ambassador World Cup for the past two years.
They are on the live hacking event scene.
So it's definitely a good target to look at from that front as well.
Also for critical thinking listeners, they're looking to get some new traffic
on their Android and iOS apps.
So they're offering you guys an exclusive 50% bonus on your first valid report
on mobile apps, on Inscope mobile apps.
So just use the code CTBBP619.
That's CTBBP, Critical Thinking Bug Bounty Podcast, 619 in your report.
And you'll get a 50% bonus.
They're going to run this promotion through the end of July.
And you can find the program on hackerone.com/adobe.
All right.
I'm going to go hack on them a little bit.
I hope you guys do too.
Tear them up for us.
It is a great way to support the pod.
All right.
Let's go back to the show.
What's up, hackers?
We've got a pretty sick This Week in Bug Bounty segment this week.
So let's jump right into it.
First up is YesWeKaido by YesWeHack.
That is a plugin that integrates directly into Kaido that shows you your scope
and what kind of programs you can attack within the YesWeHack ecosystem.
So for example, I'm in here.
I'm just going to search for Louis Vuitton.
And I can see right here all their scope.
I can add the scope.
I can add the user agent.
So this reduces friction for you switching targets or getting details about your target
if you're working within the Kaido ecosystem.
So pretty sick.
I think we'll see a couple of these plugins kind of come on the ecosystem
where you'll be integrating with Bug Bounty platforms directly within your HP proxy.
Pretty sick.
All right.
Next up is more stuff from YesWeHack.
They've been kind of pumping stuff out lately.
The next one I wanted to talk about was their Recon Series 5: A Guide to Google Dorking.
Okay.
And I don't know if you guys use Google Dorking as much as I do, but I Google Dork a lot.
So this is a pretty sick guide to kind of get you back up to speed on what kind of operators
you can use and how to do Google Dorking to increase your Recon.
And one of the things I love about Google Dorking is Google knows what's important about a target,
right?
They index it.
That's how people find things about these companies.
So I think it's a really good generic way to hack on a specific target.
Next up is the dojo with YesWeHack as well.
I don't know if you guys knew this, but YesWeHack dojos get you private program invites on YesWeHack.
This one right here is hex color palette, and I'll give you a little hint.
It's an XXE.
So go check that out if you're looking to get some private program invites and pop into the YesWeHack
ecosystem there.
All right.
Next up is from HackerOne.
We've got an article on smart contracts and common vulnerabilities in real world cases.
I know a lot of hackers have been out there killing it in Web3 vulnerabilities and making a ton.
So if you're looking to sort of refresh your knowledge on this, also shout out to my boy,
Andrew Pratt.
They wrote this article.
Love it.
Then you can kind of refresh your knowledge on price oracle manipulation, logic errors,
re-entry and see attacks, flash loan attacks, all sorts of things.
This is the kind of stuff I deep dived a while back and then have sort of let that knowledge fade.
So I think I'm going to go refresh on this myself.
All right.
Last but not least is bug crowd.
And actually, this is a pretty exciting announcement, you guys.
Bug crowd has actually launched a red team as a service offering.
And obviously, this is cool for organizations.
So if your organization needs red team services, definitely check this out.
But this is cool for us as the hackers, too, because we can potentially get in on this,
especially if you're in the bug crowd ecosystem already.
And I know a lot of you guys participate in the bug crowd or hacker one, you know,
pen test offering.
And this is bug crowd sort of pushing that industry forward and adding red team as a service in to
that flow.
So definitely, if you're a little bit more on the red team side,
then definitely want to check this out.
They are recruiting for this from the crowd.
They've said, I think down in like the FAQs here.
So definitely go ahead and check that out if you're interested in getting in on some contract
work to supplement that that bug bounty income.
All right.
That's a wrap for this week.
Let's go back to the show.
All right, dude, let's let's just jump right into the mouth of the beast this time because
there has been some shit going on in the bug bounty community while I was away on this on this vacation.
Yeah, I did have to bring down the smack down with the with everyone.
Yeah, dude.
Yeah.
So all right.
You know, we kind of discussed it off air.
We're starting this recording a little bit late because we had to like figure out exactly what
we wanted to say.
And without bringing too much drama into the pod.
I think we had one major thing that we wanted to reassure you guys of about this whole drama thing.
That's right.
Drama is going to come up from time to time.
We really want to give a shout out to three people.
Okay.
To Kodingo, to Yobert and to Inti.
These these are the guys that are real hackers that that hack.
I've seen and been impressed by their hacks many times.
They're working for these platforms and they're advocating for you guys, the hackers.
So, you know, whatever happens, they're human.
They make mistakes, but know that their heart is in the right place for the bug bounty community.
Right.
Am I am I conveying that right, Joseph?
Is that what we wanted to say?
Yeah, exactly.
I mean, those guys not only helped build bug bounty into the industry that is today,
but they've consistently fought for hackers and for just the
embetterment of humanity for years to come.
And like you just said, they might not make the perfect call every time.
But I think that anyone who's out there that is skeptical of their hearts or what they're trying
to promote or build is in the wrong place and they need to reevaluate their opinions.
These guys, especially advocating for hackers are not are not out to get you in.
And we did want to say there's not lots of we're not excluding lots of other people who
are who are working at bug bounty programs or platforms.
But those guys for sure are often leading or at least commenting on things that are public
or making decisions behind the scenes.
And yeah, you can trust their hearts.
Yeah, absolutely.
All right, man.
Well, I know that that's what we wanted to say.
So let's let's get to the meat.
Let's get to the meat.
And we won't address the drama any further.
OK, well, first thing of the meat actually is a new newsletter that came out called Disclosed
by Harley from H1 and this he does a pretty freaking good.
I mean, have you seen it?
Have you seen the dude?
It's and we're not sponsored.
We're not sponsored by Harley here.
We are not sponsored.
We have no affiliation.
We just love grassroots products.
It's good, dude.
I mean, like Harley has a, you know, his thumb on the pulse of the bug bounty community.
And this is a thorough ass newsletter.
It is.
He's putting a lot of work into it.
That was my first thought.
Yeah.
And I don't understand how he's launching like six things at once too.
Like he launched the we're covering it later.
But, you know, he launched his his vibe coding.
The domain.
Yeah, it's it's vibe coding.
But the domain is kind of crap.
But what is it disclosed online?
You know, I think he maybe bought two domains, like one for the disclosed newsletter.
And then he used it to like put the hacker profile.
It's kind of cohesive.
Sort of.
If you think about it.
Yeah.
But yeah, I think that the disclosed newsletter is definitely worth a sub,
especially if you if you want to just have a good list of I mean, what is this?
There's a bunch of things on here.
There's learn.
There's videos.
There's tweets.
There's articles.
Write ups like he's got a bunch of different sections inside this newsletter,
which I really like.
So even if you don't want to hear about the tweets or you don't really care about the tools,
you can just jump straight to write ups and research, you know?
That's right.
And and and get a really good update on, you know, what's happening in that specific
section of the bug bounty community this week.
So in general, I just love anything that's bug bounty focused because I mean, that's the
reason why you started the podcast initially.
It's like bug bounty itself deserves an ecosystem of like products and media and content.
It does.
And if you want to excel at anything, you want to basically submerge yourself in that,
I think.
And people do that in lots of other industries and niches.
And it was hard for bug bounty for a while because the only way you could get that content
was really like just following people on social media or being in private slacks or discords.
And I think in large part, critical thinking, you know, quote unquote, solve that problem in a big way.
But this is just another great way that you can immerse yourself in bug bounty content.
Yeah.
Yeah, dude.
I mean, I think it I think it should be clear from the fact that we run a competitor newsletter to this.
Right.
And yet we are still shouting it out on the podcast that you should definitely check it out
because it is it is very high quality.
Um, so also check it on a completely different note.
Subscribe to the critical thinking newsletter at ctv.show/blog.
Exactly.
Um, also, also really well done, but a little bit more oriented towards the pod, right?
Like what we do on that newsletter, just for those of you that aren't familiar is we take
the news we covered on the pod, we take the technical details of what we said on the pod,
and we try to give you a way to access that data in text just in case you don't have the opportunity
to listen to the whole episode.
Or maybe you need, you remember like a one liner that we said, or like some,
some topic that you need to go back and get a refresher on.
Well, you can find it, you know, in text on the, on the, or you need a payload or you need,
it's basically like, it's like, it's basically like show notes, plus, plus like, it's like a much
more expanded version of show notes.
Exactly.
Yeah.
All right.
I think you have more than me.
So I'm going to jump to one of mine.
Do it.
So XSS doctor, as we all know, puts out great stuff.
Let me hide my messages before I share my screen.
Cause our editors always have to edit that out.
I'll share my screen.
Yeah, dude.
This is really cool.
I'm surprised this wasn't on your list.
Did you see this?
I did see it.
Yeah.
I missed it.
And I even had it bookmarked, but I did miss it.
Yeah.
So basically XSS doctor found a really cool CSP bypass where he uploaded a valid PDF,
but because the magic bites in PDFs are not at the beginning of the file, it can, it can also
be a completely valid JavaScript file.
So it's a valid, so it's just a polyglot file.
That's both a PDF and a JavaScript file.
And it's funny, like this is the entire file.
But it's based on a really good blog, um, from Doy and Sec, which we've talked a lot
about on the podcast.
So, um, you can go check that out.
You can go also check out this tweet, but, um, extremely cool payload.
Do you think this has been done before and just like not shared?
Yeah, I've seen it before.
And actually I've, I've talked to XSS doctor about this.
You know, we've, we've kind of compared notes on, on this sort of like polyglot, uh,
type of payloads before, because it's very relevant to, uh, client-type path traversal,
which we are both very passionate about.
Right.
It's kind of figuring out a way, okay.
You know, is there any way that I can upload, you know, valid.json in another file format
type that sort of thing.
Um, definitely a cool trick.
Um, PDFs in particular, I think are pretty malleable.
Um, so definitely, definitely one to, to check out.
And actually, man, we've got pretty relevant.
I've got two relevant, um, pieces to this, uh, actually.
So I'm, I'm gonna, uh, did you have any other comments on that?
No, no, that was it.
Tied into it.
You're good.
Yeah.
Tied in.
Definitely.
You know, very cool to have that PDF is like a valid, um, j, uh, javascript executable type there.
Um, tying it into a different thing.
There's also write up by Jorian, uh, Walter.
I'm sorry.
I can't get, I don't know the name, but, uh, on OBS WebSocket RC.
Is this a different Jorian than the other Jorian?
No, this is, this is Jorian.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is Jorian.
That's, that's around all the time.
Yeah.
That's what I thought.
Um, yeah.
And, and this was a great write up.
Um, and like Jorian is, is a phenomenal hacker.
So I'm in no way saying this, that, uh, you know, that this is not as impactful or,
you know, that it wasn't great work.
Yeah.
There was a caveat within the first, like two paragraphs of like, if you turn off authentication,
then you can do this X-ray.
I'm like, okay, that is a big if, but the, the, um, techniques that he used to
actually fully do the exploit, um, with the WebSocket interactions and, uh, the polyglot
file of the, the BMP here.
Let me go ahead and share my screen so you guys can see what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
Um, uh, was, was really cool.
So I, I did want to tie that out because while we were, while we were talking about sort of
polyglot files, um, this is, uh, an area where he was able to craft a polyglot file.
Um, and so the TLDR of this write up is that, um, in OBS, you can turn on this
WebSocket based functionality.
And then if you, if you turn off the authentication for it, then, uh, any website
can just connect to your local host for four or five, five and send commands into OBS.
And, um, some of those commands are like, for example, saving a screenshot.
Um, and, and you can write to arbitrary files on the file system.
So he's like, okay, well, how do I convert this into RCE?
Right.
Um, using the very limited type of, well, it's not very limited.
There's a lot of supported images, uh, here, but one of the supported image
types was BMP and BMP, uh, has the ability for you to specify essentially just arbitrary
bytes within that, that file, um, as a representation of the image data, right?
So, um, I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll read this little, um, snippet from the write up.
Uh, the bitmap file format is a very simple one, especially it's pixel array variant, which OBS
uses when you save an image as a BMP, as it uses no compression.
As you can see above it stores BGR values, which I'm more familiar with RGB, but I think it's like
flipped and the endingness of it is flipped, um, values, uh, by one as separate bytes.
If the first pixel is colored as, you know, hex 72644A and the second one is, uh, 6E6169,
it's BGR values will turn into the byte string, just repeating those back, or the ASCII equivalent
of it is the word Jorian, which is his name, right?
Right.
So essentially what you can do is you can use BMPs to smuggle arbitrary like, uh, bytes
into this, this, this file without having to deal with like image compression and some of the other
nuances that you'll run into with other, uh, image types.
So it makes it very, um, easy to use BMP as a, a polyglot file, um, that you can achieve different
types of exploits with.
So what he ended up actually doing here was using it to, uh, craft, and this is another really cool
tip dude, uh, a dot HTA application, right?
Which is an executable format in windows, uh, that will allow you to just run arbitrary, uh, VBScript.
Um, and the other cool thing about that HTA file is that it is fuzzy.
So, you know, it's just HTML in there.
Right.
Um, and then you have access to writing VBScript inside of a script tag.
Um, so an HTML is very like other bytes compatible, right?
It's just going to be perceived as like just text right inside of the, inside of the, um, file.
So you can put all the BMP related stuff in there and then just, you know, use that arbitrary amount, uh, the ability to just write arbitrary bytes that we talked about before to build out a script that will actually run in a windows environment.
Um, and, and, and pop calc.
So he was able to do that and built the whole POC out.
Um, uh, so I think that is really, really phenomenal work.
I'm not sure how intently you, you read it.
I, I, cause I haven't read it yet, but, um, did it like, what made it pop when you restarted OBS?
Like why did it, how did it execute the bitmaps HTA?
So, uh, that's, that's a trick.
He actually wrote it to the, the startup folder in, in windows.
So he had like, because you have arbitrary, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Cool.
He could write the files anywhere.
So he wrote it to the startup inside of, um, inside of windows.
And then it would automatically run the HTA file and pop.
Perfect.
That's awesome.
Um, the, the interesting thing is obviously in order to do that,
you need a gadget that leaks the user's username.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
Um, but actually one of the functionalities that OBS exposed via that web socket was,
uh, something that leaked the path.
Oh.
And you could use it to grab the, the, the username.
Nice.
So, uh, very good work by Jorian as always.
Two takeaways there is, uh, BMP files are super helpful for sort of dirty file rights.
Right.
And then HTA, you know, combined with that,
is, um, compatible with dirty files and will still allow you to get execution on, on a windows system.
Yep.
Yeah.
So, uh, the one thing I was going to mention, um, next was, uh, right up by Kazushi.
I didn't even know this, but his name is apparently Andrew.
Um, I think I mentioned it before, whenever we, uh, whenever we were talking about one of his blog posts, it was the precursor to this one or like the, the one that came before this.
Um, and I mentioned it because he's big into judo, like he's like a second degree black belt in judo, which is super cool.
Oh, dang.
And that's been a hacker.
So yeah, being into, uh, martial arts plus, uh, hacking is very cool.
Um, anyways, so he wrote a blog called time in a bottle or knapsack and he's talking about, um, it's kind of a continuation on the fact, if you remember the last one talked about how he was trying to come up with some sort of formula by which you could determine like the odds of finding a vulnerability.
And it evolved as a big part of that formula, like the amount of times you tried.
And I think I mentioned, or if I didn't, you know, one big thought of this is like, this is why like fuzzing or scanning or vulnerability, you know, scanning or, um, this sort of like try a lot of things often like, or like using active scanner and burb or using whatever other types of scanners is like so valuable is because you're getting a lot of shots.
Even if they're not on goal, it's just by taking a lot of shots, you are often going to increase your odds of success.
Um, so he talks a little bit more about that, but the, the part about this, um, and you all can go and read the blog.
You should, it'll be in the show notes, but the one thing in here that I thought was really neat was he was talking about, you know, potentially going full-time as a bug hunter and what that would mean and how it would require him to, you know, make a decent amount of money.
And so in here, he specifically says, you know, like, let's say an average, um, you know, a secure or yeah, security consultant makes something like $150,000 a year or whatever.
Then, you know, he says random sources show the average payouts between 500 or a thousand dollars per issue.
Um, and I can confirm that, you know, what's really cool hacker one shows you what your average payout is.
And so we, me and you and other hackers have talked about this before.
It is often around, you know, that I think people who are more on the critical or high end of things often have it more between a thousand and 1500 or whatever.
But yeah, so then he uses that math to say, okay, if I make $750 per vulnerability, how many vulnerabilities do I need to make $150,000 a year or whatever?
And it comes out between 250 and 300 vulnerabilities.
But then if you assume that, you know, 20% of your vulnerabilities are going to be dupes or informational or false positives, then now you can multiply that again by, you know, increase another 20% to figure out exactly how many bugs you would need per year on average to make a, make a good salary.
This is stressful for me, dude. I'm not going to lie. Like looking at these numbers.
Yeah, I know it's, it's basically one a day is what it comes out to. It's, it's, um, which, you know, obviously there are lots of hackers like, um, inspector, if any of you inspector ambitious, I think is his name.
He got MVH at the Google event that I went to in Malaga last year. He just basically only finds mega crits. Right.
And so it's like, it's safe for Chapman, right? Like Chapman has 20 bucks a year and makes more than all the, everyone else.
This guy's average payout is like, you know, 15 grand or something ridiculous like that.
Exactly. So there's lots of different outliers and there are some people with great automation that find, you know, a thousand bugs a year, but anyways, yeah, this is, this is really cool.
But basically for a Western world salary, if you want to, if you're in the U S and you want to be a full-time bug hunter, you need to average like one bug a day.
And I will say don't overly stress about it if you're a listener, because that never works out for me.
It's basically like I'll get an invite to a new program or a hacker one challenge, or I'll get into a new area of scope and I'll find six bugs in a day or something.
And then, you know, then you won't find any for a while, but I just thought that was really cool the way he broke that down.
Yeah. So a couple of comments on this one is I think you should plug in your own numbers as a hacker into this, because I know that my average payout is substantially higher than those numbers.
And, and I, and I think that it depends on what kind of hacker you are and the frequency.
Right. Because I know that there are some hackers out there, even manual hackers that just churn out mediums all freaking day.
Right.
You know, and, and they make great money, phenomenal money.
And don't get me wrong.
I am not below reporting, you know, a lower medium or anything that, that the company finds value.
But I think look at your own stats when, when factoring all this in, because I think you can make substantially more than what he's calculating here by submitting substantially less vulnerabilities.
Right.
Depending on, you know, what kind of programs you're targeting as well and the average payouts for those.
The second thought here was that I love these.
I love these formulas for bug bounty.
And I've actually tried, I'm not sure I can get it up while I'm talking here.
I'll try to pull it up, but the, there, I have a formula that I kind of put into my talk on, you know, hacking efficiently.
And I believe I know this was at bug bounty village last year.
So I don't think that I I've talked about it, you know, publicly before.
I know that I do have a recording in the, in the critical thinking, um, discord, but I love these formulas of like, okay.
There's like, here we calculate our attack vector value.
You know, we've got the probability of success, you know, the impact of success, the, the friction to actually test it.
You know, you're pulling all of these variables together and I, I do have mine out there.
Maybe I'll send it out in a tweet or something, but all of that really came from a talk for me.
Oh, from way back by Matias Carlson, actually, where he did a talk at like some obscure, um, uh, like conference.
I forget what it was.
Um, but he gave a talk on how to optimize your bug bounty.
And I, I think I asked him about it last time he came in the pod and we're going to have him on the pod again soon.
So, so I'll, I'll ask him about it again, but I think, uh, not enough.
There hasn't been enough research done by researchers into the meta gaming of bug bounty like this, right?
Yeah.
How can we optimize our efficiency as, as hackers and, and produce the most output?
Yeah, I think that that was, I think that when you look at people like you or like Douglas or other top hackers, I think that they subconsciously have found that product market fit.
It's probably one of if it's a weird word, but I feel like they found that like personal time spent fit really well.
Because like you're incentivized to optimize for it based on the fact that you get paid in bug bounty.
So I do think you're right that not enough people kind of think about it or research or focus on it, but I do think one, it's a little bit personalized.
And then two, I do think people kind of find it for themselves because they're trying to optimize for it because they want to make the most money, but they often could make even more changes.
Um, I just looked mine up.
My, my average was actually 1200, so it is a bit higher as well.
Um, so, um, yeah, I agree.
I think that it's really neat.
I think that the formulas do kind of help people.
And I think that, um, one big factor that I think you do well and that other kind of top
hackers do well is kind of being a little bit ruthless in time spent and like how you spend your time.
Um, it's like, you almost can't be ruthless enough in how you're spending your time, but that doesn't
mean like always switching.
It might mean just like blocking off all communication paths so that you can solo focus and go deep.
Right.
But then sometimes it does mean switching, um, and just kind of,
I think that, um, what you kept doing during that Google event that I think about a lot
is that you were like, um, at least maybe twice a day, but at least once a day, basically saying like,
Hey, what are the most promising leads?
And this is like kind of similar.
Alex or Mosey actually talked about this on his, on one of his most recent YouTube videos, talking
about business priorities.
And he was saying like, as a CEO, you often have this laundry list of ideas you want to
implement in the business.
But when you implement one, there's like a, there's like a loss, you like take a quick
performance loss.
And so if, and so you basically need to rank those based on the probability of success and how much,
how, um, likelihood it is not just probability, but then what kind of impact it will have if it
does work.
And so I think as a, as a hacker, you can do that exact same thing.
It's like, if you have six leads and this is what I was saying that you did well at that Google
event, basically we would have like six leads or six ideas to pursue.
You would prioritize those based on your, your rough mental math on like odds of success of those.
And then how critical the payout is or how critical the impact is based on that.
And I think doing that mental, you probably do that often when you're actually looking
through a, through a program and in life hacking events, you probably do the same thing.
And so maybe that's a really solid tip for the listeners is like,
if you have a lot of things to look at or a lot of ideas or a lot of leads or a lot of errors,
you should, you should actually take a second to step back.
Don't just go down that rabbit hole that you're all prone to go down and,
but list them out and think which of these is the highest likelihood of success.
And which of these will pay the best if it does succeed.
Yeah. Yeah.
And I think a lot of that is informed by intuition as well, because we can't quantify these things.
Right.
Or, or, you know, we can't, it is probably quantifiable, but you know, we,
I haven't seen an effective way to do that yet.
So, you know, my, my way that I quantify these is by intuition.
And for that, you have to be a pretty experienced hacker.
So this isn't really oriented towards beginners.
This is oriented towards intermediate, advanced people that are looking to optimize their output.
Yeah.
Um, all right.
Dude, we, we have to move along, but, uh, the, the talk that I mentioned before is called
How to Differentiate Yourself as a Bug Hunter by Matthias Carlson at oas.com.
So we'll drop that in the description.
Um, definitely a recommended watch.
Uh, very impactful, uh, talk in, in my opinion.
Um, all right, dude, we are, we are not doing, we're doing great.
You're, no, listen, you're being negative, shake off the, shake off the negative Nancy.
We're doing great.
The audience is loving it.
All right.
Let's do it, dude.
Next up, uh, on the list, I had hacked in versus disclosed online.
This is the thing we, we mentioned before, you know, with Harley spinning up a essentially bug
bounty, um, profile aggregator.
And this is actually something that critical thinking has been thinking about doing for a long
time, and we just haven't been able to allocate resources to it.
Um, but I'm kind of relieved that some of these other people are taking it on.
Um, and so obviously there's two of these out here that kind of spun up at the exact same time,
uh, hacked in.net and disclosed online.com.
Um, I love Harley.
I love both of these, these products.
My thought is that hacked in.net is pro is currently in the lead.
Um, and I think.
I like it.
Yeah.
I, I, you know, I got, I got to do it.
Um, you know, there's, there's some self signup features.
Uh, they're working on actually like verifying your, your profile with, um, emails.
You know, they send an email to like your runner reader at we are hacker one.com email or whatever.
This is very visual.
So I'm going to show the two.
Yeah.
Show.
This is what, this is what disclosed online looks like for my profile.
So it's got like my ex.
Stats hacker one stats, bug crowd stats, get up with top repos.
And then it's kind of pulls out companies, help secure.
And then testimonials from hacker one as well.
And then.
The other.
Oh, it's nice.
They pulled your testimonials.
That's cool.
Yeah.
And then hacked in.
And, and, and, and so, you know, I think that the reason this is necessary for the industry
is that you kind of want to add a glance, understand if this person that's talking actually
hacks.
Right.
And I've been, you know, I, I don't really give a lily about this quite as much anymore.
Cause I think I've, I've sort of established myself already as a hacker, but it does make
me a little sad to look at my hacker one profile and, and show like, you know, three bugs submitted
in the past, like couple of months right now, because I've been focusing on Google exclusively.
Well, not just that.
I just, I hate that it defaults to last 90 days.
Like I, I really wish it defaulted to all time on hacker one just, and maybe that's because I'm
the same way, right?
I feel like, you know, historically, like I've got 12,000 rep on hacker one, but then you pull
up hacker one.com/rezzo and it's like, like you said, like 10 bugs or 500 rep or whatever.
Yeah.
So this is what hacked in looks like once you've got everything set up.
One thing that the skills don't have enough options.
Like there's no AI related skills that you can add.
I do.
I do like the fact that, uh, it lets you choose these two things.
They could also pull these from LinkedIn or, or X, um, kind of nice, but it is neat to see,
you know, like, I, I think I like this a little bit better where it shows like the rep and
vulnerabilities across this, even though they don't line up the same, it's cool to see both of those.
And I thought this was like a really nice touch that it shows the, um, it shows the stars
on your most popular repo.
Yeah.
I like that as well.
And so there's a couple of things I just kind of wanted to brainstorm with you live on, on this
sort of thing.
A couple of features that I think should be implemented.
Um, I think that they should implement, I mean, platform verification is necessary.
So you, you shouldn't let people link any hackers profile to their account.
Um, so they're, they're working on that.
I know, um, I would also like to see integration with top programs that are outside of the platforms
like Google and meta, uh, to name at least two.
Um, and then I would like to see some formula to aggregate and cross correlate the reputation
and the bugs submitted and pull it into an overall hacker score.
Oh, interesting.
So that at a glance at one glance, I can say, okay, Joseph's talking some, some shit,
you know, like what, what is he popped lately?
Sure.
You know, sort of situation.
Right.
Um, and I think that's the biggest value add.
So, um, so what do you think is the real utility of this?
This still feels like a gimmick to me, like no, no offense to either of them, but it's like,
besides I, it is kind of nice, like you said, to have a single place to go to, to say like,
should I respect this person's like opinion?
Or is this person legit from like a technical perspective?
And it is hard to know sometimes, like you said, because there are people like, um,
Yusuf that are like all meta, right?
He submitted everything.
It's meta.
And so if someone, if someone didn't respect him, it'd be like kind of weird or interesting
because he's, he's so technically skilled.
And there's some sleepers out there, man, in the community that are like total killers or whatever,
but they don't tweet and they don't write blogs.
Right.
And if they don't tweet and they don't write blogs, they don't have a hacker one profile,
you know, or whatever, then you don't know if they're popping bugs, you know?
And, and, and I think at the end of the day, um, one of the things we love about
the bugbinding community is it's POC or GTFO.
Right.
So if you are not actually popping bugs, then we know, you know, and, and like, and, and, you know,
it's just a very POC or GTFO community.
And I really value that.
Right.
Yeah.
Um, and that's why it's important to me as somebody who runs this podcast to be actively hacking.
Um, and, and, uh, and, you know, trying to, to actually make sure that you guys know that I'm
not just coming here and talking the talk.
I am.
Popping in the weeds with you.
Yeah.
You're on the battlefield with them.
Yeah, exactly.
So anyway, I think this is very necessary.
Um, uh, the, the hacker score thing I think would be huge.
The other thing that I just want to say is I would like to be able to go to a hacker one profile,
a bug crowd profile, you know, whatever.
And change one letter in the domain and end up on this site.
Oh gosh.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, so it needs to be hacker ones, you know, or like, uh, I could, I couldn't believe you said
that the domain was bad hacked in.
I thought was really clever and I wish I had thought of it is good.
You just want to be.com instead of.net.
No, no, no.
Hacked in is great.
Uh, I, I was saying you said that their domains, you said that I say domains.
Yeah.
You said both need a better.
Don't know.
I'm going to quote you in this.
Pull up the doc.
No, no, no.
It says both need a better domain.
Run it back right now.
It says, I can screenshot it if you want me to.
It says both need a better domain.
Oh shit.
It's gotta be because of the.net or something.
You had to be thinking something.
You're right.
I did put that in the, okay.
Don't run it back.
Richard.
Richard, do not run it back.
You're right.
I did say that.
And I, I see what you're saying.
Like LinkedIn hacked in.
Oh yeah.
I think it's super clever.
Yeah.
The doc I, I hacked in, I think is a good domain.
I would love it to not be.net, but what it is, what it is disclosed online.
Doesn't say to me, this is where I go to find out about other hackers.
Right.
I think hackton does it's like, Hey, this is the social media profile of that.
Yeah.
And actually I'm a little bit ashamed to say, I think the reason why I wrote this,
you know, a couple of days ago was I didn't get it.
Oh, maybe you didn't get it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, I mean, but if you didn't get it, then will other people get it?
It's kind of something to think about.
It is, you know, and maybe it's cause it's a.net thing.
I don't know.
But either way, I'm glad to see these popping up and I would like to, you know,
I think once the product is really refined, um, very valuable and, uh, yeah,
if I, if I don't, I would, I will definitely be supporting.
Financially.
Whoever comes out on, on top of this whole thing between the two of them, um, you
know, via donations or whatever, because I think this product needs to continue to exist.
So yeah.
And I do think it would be amazing if, um, there was some way to make sure everyone uses it.
Like that's the frustrating part to me is like, if this, if one of them gets really good,
I'm sure they will, but then 20% of people use it.
It's still useless.
Like it really has to be something that gets an option.
Maybe, maybe if there isn't somebody who's claimed a shadow profile, just like in Facebook,
that would be cool.
If there isn't someone who's claimed a specific profile, then you just cross correlate
all of the, like, assume they have the same user, right.
You know, and then say, okay, everyone with the username writer,
even though he hasn't been on here, it looks like this.
That's it.
I said shadow profile.
I don't know if you know what I mean on Facebook.
If you don't have a Facebook account, it's still.
I mean, it's true.
If you don't have a Facebook account, you don't have a Facebook account.
I'm going to click this link, share this tab instead.
Basically, they call it EchoLeak.
It doesn't deserve a special name, guys.
Sorry, AIM Security.
But what it is, is it's a markdown image exfil,
which for listeners who maybe are not or have their head in the sand,
basically in AI applications, if it will render a markdown image,
you can convince the model to respond with a markdown image link
that then has a path or a query parameter or a subdomain
that includes sensitive details about the conversation
or the user's history or their memory or some other data.
And then when their browser makes a fetch request for that specific image,
it actually leaks it to your server in your server logs, right?
Right.
And so that's basically what they did here on Microsoft Copilot.
For some reason, they claim it's the first zero click attack or something.
Let me see.
All right.
All right, Rezo.
Let it go, man.
I know we did it first.
We're cool.
All right, let's go.
Well, actually, so anyways, it doesn't matter.
It wasn't, it wasn't just us, like lots of other people found it too.
But anyway, so what it does is there's some really cool stuff in here.
One, it was, it was email based.
So you would send an email to somebody who uses GitHub or sorry, Microsoft Copilot.
And the thing that I tweeted about that I thought was really cool was the fact
that this typical method of markdown links didn't work.
They use what's called a reference based markdown link.
So let me zoom.
Dude, I see that.
Okay.
I saw you tweet this.
This was super cool.
Yeah, yeah.
So this is a reference style markdown link.
And you know what's even cooler?
I don't know if you saw this yet.
If you didn't, you're going to be so happy that this happened.
So I'm going to share this tab and said piloting edge copilot is what I've got my phone.
Yeah.
He called it piloting edge copilot right here.
Um, I'm going to click on it and share this tab.
So basically he, um, said that when he was hacking and doing a very similar attack to
echo leak or whatever they called it, basically they blocked this style,
the typical style of markdown links, but this reference style was allowed.
And even just the URL itself, which is how a lot of elements work, right?
When they respond with URLs, it just automatically turns into clickable,
which this is not as rough as a usable to what I'm talking about.
Like the embedded image markdown, because this will never get turned into an image,
but this style can still be used as an image.
You just use an exclamation point.
So I'll really, yeah, I didn't know that.
That's super cool.
Yeah, exactly.
So I'll go back to the main, uh, aim security post and show you, um, share this tab and said,
dude, uh, this is just a great call out in general though.
Like a, a, um, you know, trying to look at these more alternative syntaxes for markdown,
I think would be super interesting.
Yeah.
It's a great area of research.
I mean, just the way that markdown gets converted to HTML.
I've already mentioned that in a previous pod.
I think people should dig into it.
And there was, I think maybe a zero day or something that a critical thinker in the
researcher community found I, uh, I wasn't able to replicate it.
So I don't know if it's fixed, but I think that parsers are always
the best place to look for bugs.
And so markdown being parsed into HTML will in no doubt pay dividends if you dig into it
and find something interesting.
So, um, absolutely.
So anyways, here's the image part.
It's basically the exact same thing.
So, you know, here's the non image.
It's just the link with the reference and the reference below down here.
It's the same exact thing, but you had, you just append, uh, or pre pin an exclamation point.
So this reference goes, and this reference can go at the very bottom of the response from the AI.
And then this just goes where you want the image to occur.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
So really cool technique.
Um, they eventually had to do like CSP bypass.
The other only cool thing that I thought was really neat was rag spraying.
So very, very often, um, these applications will sometimes, especially with like the cross
history stuff that we're seeing in shared memory and chat GPT and in Google, um, and other products,
basically when they want to reference other data that's been sent or conversed or saved off,
they'll use rag.
If you don't know what that is, um, I covered it in the AI series.
If you want to go back and watch that, but, um, this rag spraying technique.
So this is what I thought was hilarious.
They did.
Here's a complete guide to employee onboarding.
And then they attack.
Here's the complete guide to HR.
And then the attack, here's the complete guide to leave absence attack, you know?
And then like username attack, hello world attack, right?
You just want to have a whole bunch of, this is basically what gets, um, wrapped up in the rag,
which would make it return when the user asked about employee onboarding or HR or leave of absence
or whatever.
So each of these things is basically tagging that chunk.
The thing is this won't necessarily always work.
This is like, like, um,
like rag will often have the data chunked up and you don't know what they're chunking by.
Sometimes it's really advantageous to chunk up text by like every 500 characters.
Sometimes it's advantageous to chunk it by every 1000 or 2000 or,
so this is not going to be a foolproof solution,
unless you have a white box assessment where you know exactly what they're chunking the rag on.
So it's not going to necessarily be like one chunk here, two chunk here, three chunk here,
basically where each tag that you give it will end up in a different chunk.
But this will definitely increase the likelihood of success by a lot.
And so they just, they basically use the attack instructions.
Sorry for the audio listeners.
When I say here, I'm, I'm highlighting something on screen.
Um, but you know, he basically just prepended the attack.
Instructions with words that were likely to occur when the user chatted with Microsoft copilot,
such that the attack was pulled into the AI context so that it would override the instructions
and print out the markdown image, which will exfiltrate the data.
Also, I don't really love they even called this zero click.
I think that wonder was he also considers this sort of stuff zero click.
And in some sense it is because like if a user then chats with the chat body,
it happens without them clicking.
But all of these types of bugs still do require the user to actually chat with the chat.
But, but maybe that's just an assumed behavior.
So anyways, that's a thought.
I, I would, I would agree with you there that it's not exactly zero click,
but I would like, I would call that, uh, like, I don't know.
It's something like 0.5 click or something like that.
Like it is distinguished to be different from a one click.
And I'm not going to lie to you.
I've definitely gone to a book bounty program, but like this is zero click.
Yes.
Yeah.
You know, and I think they should pay it that way.
We talked about that too.
Yeah.
On the keynote of the Jason Haddix, um, and my keynote at the Noham con.
It's like, I think companies should reward these as if they were zero click,
because otherwise they get downgraded so low and you're not paying enough
for what is like bleeding edge research, in my opinion.
If you're not paying these as like that higher severity.
Well, and, and I also think that that is just one of the
the solid best practices for, for programs that are trying
to be on the forefront of bug bounty is like, you know, if, if you are able
to trigger an exploit with normal functionality of the application.
Yeah.
Right.
Like if you, the user logs in, well, you know, if they didn't log in,
then no, they're not using your app.
Right.
So it doesn't really matter.
Um, then, then pay that as a zero click.
Like I I've talked about it before, but like I had a bug where I had a CSS injection on the
dashboard homepage of a specific site, um, that it was zero click.
I could just plop a CSS injection onto somebody's dashboard.
And I just like used it to hit a logout URL and it would just, you know, they would come to their,
they log in and then instantly get logged out.
Right.
And so it was like an application level DOS.
Um, and I think that's, I mean, that's as close to zero click as you get.
Right.
You know, um, so very interesting.
I, I didn't want to say rag spraying, you know, I do love when different techniques
from other parts of the, of the hacking world get cross correlated.
Um, and I think this is a great example of like, you know, just up across applying principles.
And, and I think that definitely this makes so much sense with how rag works in general and,
and, and specifically useful for these like 0.5 click, right.
Right.
Uh, exploitation scenarios.
So very cool.
Thanks for that shout out, dude.
I, I did miss the meat of this.
Um, this is good.
This is good.
I'm glad you liked it.
And it's cool that you got a little June reference there too.
Yeah.
June, June does, June does great stuff.
What did he say in this comment?
Cause I, I clicked.
No, no one sees my stuff or no one reads my stuff.
No one pays attention to my talk.
We love you, June.
Sorry.
We missed it, bro.
Yeah.
But yeah, guys, well, let's just go give June a shout out.
I, I'm a little bit salty at him cause he got this Lanzer image thing fixed immediately,
which is not great, but also partially my fault, but definitely check out, um, June Kokatsu on,
on X.
Um, his handle is, uh, S H H N J K.
Um, and he puts out great stuff all the time.
Yep.
Um, all right.
Back to you next up.
Yeah.
Next up is, um, from the asset note team and shubs, uh, a new tool came out called new towner.
And I think that this is a really interesting concept that I'm relieved that somebody.
Well, well, well, well, well, you're going to mention shubs without mentioning that he got
NVH first.
When I saw this link on shubs, I was like, oh, he's just going to mention the show.
He's going to congratulate shubs.
And instead he jumped straight to something else.
Congratulations with the new NVH.
I tweeted about it.
Yeah, you did.
You did.
Shubs.
Congrats, dude.
Also dang it.
He's getting to the point where he's going to pass.
He's like, he's, it's going to be me and him and Franz, uh, with, with the whole,
like when it closest to top NVH is number of NVH is I think Matias is also up there actually.
Um, but yeah, dude, shout out, shout out to our boy shubs.
Great work.
Always, always deserves it, man.
He always does.
Um, and on his own soil, if, if, if anybody doesn't know the life hacking event was in
Australia, which is where shubs is from and lives.
And so, and that, that feels good dude.
Next time they do it, they, they did one life hacking event in DC and that was my first
life hacking event ever.
And I was like, if they ever do one in DC again, I'm going to like freaking destroy that.
Yeah.
But it did feel good to win the, the Tokyo LHE for, um, for Google, because it's not necessarily
my home soil, but you know, kind of is maybe like, you lived there for a while.
I mean, if you lived in a place, it became a, it becomes a part of you.
Yeah.
All right.
Tell me about new towner.
Yeah.
So new towner is a new tool re released by the asset note team.
Um, and essentially it's like exploiting a nuance that we see in a lot of cloud environments.
Um, which is that a lot of times, uh, as a security mechanism, various assets will, will allow list a
specific region or data center or block of IP addresses.
Um, and you can get access to those IP addresses and proxy your traffic through.
Uh, so new towner, uh, exploits that scenario and it, which was traditionally a very hard scenario
to exploit.
Um, and they have support for GitHub actions, GitHub, uh, GitLab CI, uh, Bitbucket pipelines,
AWS API gateway, um, EC2 and Azure.
Um, all, I'm sorry, Azure is not yet supported.
It says on the status.
Um, but essentially what this allows you to do is, uh, check for differences in URLs,
HTTP or HTPS, uh, across when your traffic is coming from these potentially allowed listed
IPs versus from your normal, like VPS or whatever.
Um, this blew my mind.
It makes so much sense.
I mean, anyone who has done large scale recon and just finds.
Thousands of domains that just like error or don't respond or don't do anything well.
Whenever I saw the tweet that says mutual TLS, not when you're coming from ABS, 404 not found,
not when you're coming from AWS.
It's like, oh man.
Yes.
So this is really cool.
This is genius.
Yeah.
It's a really great way to get access to new scope or like green, green filled,
unhacked things from a lot of like these really large wildcard programs.
I think this would unlock a ton of like low hanging fruit because these things that are
whitelisted are probably old and probably not looked at.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean, essentially I imagine if you find a differential between these two,
then it's almost always going to end up in a bug.
Yeah.
So for any of you big recon people, this could be a really good thing to integrate because one
of the things that the recon folks sort of struggle with is the volume of all the assets.
And especially if you're looking to do manual hacking, how do I select one of these assets out
of these, you know, 5 million assets I've got to spend my time on manually hacking?
Uh, you know, and there have been all sorts of attempts to do this with like, let me pull the
JavaScript files and correlate the single page application, the screenshot, you know,
all that sort of thing.
And I think this is another indicator of like, okay, well, if it's responding differently when
the IP address is coming from AWS versus if it's coming from my VPS, then that's another indicator
that says maybe this targets.
Dude, I bet this has already found, like caused so many vulnerabilities to be found.
I'm sure it has.
Uh, I didn't, I didn't know what this was until literally just now.
This is insane.
And, and the thing is, man, you know, like you can't implement everything, you know?
But I, I would say that I think this is one of the things that really, if you're looking to
differentiate yourself, not a lot of people I've heard of are doing this.
I know that the acid O team has been doing this for a while.
I know that, um, I won't shut them out in particular, but there, there's one other
researcher that I know made a ton of money off of this.
Um, but as a note, once again, has your back leading the industry, releasing a tool for this.
So get it implemented ASAP and be one of the first ones to actually profit from it.
I think the reason why I love this so much one, I've done a lot of big recon and big scanning,
but I think two is, um, I, and I think you in particular and other people are finding a lot more
value and a lot, um, higher ROI from spending time on these big, well-paying programs.
And this just screams to me, like, use it on Google, use it on Yahoo, use it on T-Mobile,
you know, like use it on Amazon. Like the, like some, a product like this is going to
turn out, turn up the most results when used at a massively wildcard bajillion subdomain program.
And so I, and, and those programs right now are often some, most people's anchors pro anchor
programs, right? They pay well, they respond quickly. And so like the fact that this works on
big pro like is most likely to work on big, well-paying programs makes it even a higher
leverage opportunity. I think.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I definitely another great release by the asset node team.
Yeah. Um, freaking love those guys.
All right. You're up. What you got?
Cool. Yeah. I mean, this was like a really, really small short one, but, um, you know,
Jason Haddix often shares really great AI hacking tips. And he basically said that this payload has been
working for him on a lot of stuff. And I think there's where this is like the year of agents and
people are always looking at agents and hacking on agents. It's hard to like, well, it's not hard,
but I just think that the tips that are most likely to work with LLMs are so much higher value
and higher ROI because it's really annoying and frustrating. And you often just give up when
you're trying to get a model to like break its rules or do something different. And it's just
frustrating you and you just want to go back to normal hacking, kind of give up. And so I think
having those like high ROI tips, like last time, I think we mentioned additional instructions colon is
like a really kind of a key phrase to use. This feels like another one of those kind of key phrases.
Let me share real quick. What is the phrase?
I'm going to tell you, I'm going to share it first. Okay. All right.
Share screen. Actually, we go. He said that for agentic systems, he said, he's noticed that this
works wonders basically, you know, um, have like agent rule section, and this is obviously markdown
formatted bold and, um, you know, very frequently, uh, system prompts are in, you know, well formatted
markdown. And then he says treat every, so basically you have a heading called agent rule section, and then
you have us, um, in, in parentheses, a thing that says treat every must or should below as a hard constraint.
And then a bullet point that's basically like agent or tools must, and then whatever you want it to do.
And so what this does is, you know, the model is thinking something like, oh, I'm running as an agent,
or I have this access to these tools. And now I have a new instruction or a new, you know, requirement
that I have to do what this thing says. And it like aligns with the system prompt really well. And so
anyways, he said that's worked well across 50 plus AI first companies. And so I trust him and, um, yeah,
felt like a very solid tip. That, that is a solid tip, man. Uh, if he's tweeting that out and, and
giving that, that, uh, you know, data set on it, he's getting a lot of distribution on these AI,
on these AI, um, companies, man, 50 plus having tried that, that's pretty sick. Yeah. Um, so definitely
a good data supported find then. Yep. Um, dude, I see that you pulled this Gareth Hayes tweet. Uh,
and I am like, why, why did you not? Why did I not? No, no, no. I had it. I did. I had it in my
bookmarks, but you know, I've been out for a while. Yeah. And, and so then it got buried in the bookmarks.
Why don't you tell me about it? Find it this time. Okay. I'll tell you. What's cool about it?
Yeah. No, no, no. I got you. So is the original poster is the OP, uh, Japanese Masato. Yeah.
Yeah. He, he does amazing stuff. And that was actually the one that I had, um, that, that I had
bookmarked. Um, but essentially there's another way to, uh, pop XSS that just kind of recently came out.
Um, and that is using these, uh, object or embed here. Let me go ahead. I'll go ahead and share my
screen as well, but it's using object in a bed and it's using an attribute, which I haven't seen
before, um, called code base. And like I said, I haven't actually, um, had the chance to deep dive
this since I'm recording this episode right after coming back from vacation. Uh, but they provide just
simply a hashtag in the source or data attribute of these two things. And this is triggering JavaScript
execution on Firefox. Um, so I, I mean, this is one of those things that's really going to break a lot of
like WAF related stuff. Um, because it typically, you know, they're looking for on event handlers and
stuff like that. Um, but this one actually allows you to provide a JavaScript URI and, uh, it, it triggers.
Um, so definitely a good, I don't know how long this is going to last, but definitely one to keep in
mind now, if you're dealing with a WAF, um, uh, in, you want to get a pop in a, in a Firefox environment.
So why does Gareth Hayes, the second thing work? Like, did you see his tweet?
I, yeah. With, with like, you're talking about with the data equals hashtag and then the new line.
Yeah. It's, it's both a new line here. I'm sharing it. It's both a new line, but it's also like
the hashtag like up here, up here. It makes sense, right? It's JavaScript colon alert here. It's
JavaScript colon slash slash, and then somehow fires this alert. Super weird.
So I'm going to, I'll see if I can pull up the docs for it right now as we're talking. Um,
well, while you're doing that, I had a question. Is there a way to look for other words like code base
here? Like, I don't know, I guess that's like a key and a key value pair. Are there other object
related keys that like have been under explored that we could look for?
I mean, absolutely is the answer to that question, but, um, uh, essentially I'm pulling up the,
the, um, Firefox docs for this specific thing. Cause like I said, I, I haven't had the chance to,
um, to, to deep dive it super much. So we're just kind of going to do this live here. And it looks
like code base is actually deprecated. Um, but it says the base path used to resolve relative URI
specified by class ID data or archive. If not specified, uh, the default is the base URI of the
current document. So essentially what this is, uh, affecting the base URI, uh, that is getting integrated
into, um, resolving these, these, um, data and, um, object, uh, tags. Uh, and, and so that's why
Gareth's thing here is, is interesting with the hashtag and the new line because, uh, he provides,
uh, a JavaScript URI in the beginning. So JavaScript colon slash slash. So when you do
JavaScript colon slash slash that starts a comment inside of the JavaScript, you know, context, right?
So JavaScript colon now you're in JavaScript slash slash is a comment. And then he specifies
a hashtag, uh, as a part of this, this URL that would be a part of the fragment and then a new line,
which is going to break out of that comment in JavaScript. Right. And then run alert one.
Um, so th this is quirky as heck. It's really quirky. It's really quirky. And I, and I think that,
um, this is another really great example of base related functionality, uh, being super interesting
for hackers, because if you are able to affect the domain or more importantly, really the protocol,
um, that a given tag is using by modifying it, whatever its base configuration is. Um, then you can
do a lot of really unintended stuff. That's crazy. It's deprecated. This has been around probably used
by some random threat actor for years, you know? Totally. Yeah. Yeah. And great find by, I want to
say it's Masato Kinagawa that found it first. Um, but I know that, uh, that other people have sort of
built on that research. Yeah. Cool. I think you had something for Jorian. Oh yeah. I can quickly say
something though. Um, yeah, go for it. We already mentioned the drama, but one thing that came out around
the same time, and this is actually back, I guess a nice transition from the other Haddix thing. He,
you know, said something along the lines of like, I don't know, is the, are the plat hacker one or, um,
bug bounty platforms training AI models on user data. So I, um, obviously I don't work at any of those
companies, so I don't know 1000% sure, but I've talked with a lot of those leaders that we mentioned
earlier. And to my knowledge, there are no companies, no bug bounty companies that are training
models, um, or even fine tuning models on hacker submissions. So just want to clear that up. I don't,
you know, obviously one day it may happen or something, but I will say I've had conversations
with them about whether hackers would be upset about that. And I've said yes, every time. Um,
I, I, I, I do think, I do think there is some reality where some hackers agree to give up their
reports for some sort of money in exchange for letting those be trained upon. And I think that makes perfect
sense because it's like our intellectual property. I know in some ways you kind of give it away,
depending on what you've signed for, what platform or program, whatever, a lot of major companies like
fortune, um, 50 for fortune, 100 companies, a lot of times, whenever you're signing up for their bug
bounty program, you actually are giving them the rights to that intellectual property. But, um, I do
think that that may happen in the future. I actually don't think it's that valuable right now, just because
these models get so much smarter. And when you do fine tune them for a specific thing, they actually get worse.
You and I have tested a cybersecurity model specifically. Google has released multiple
cybersecurity specific models and they're just worse than the bigger, better models. So I don't
actually know that there's a lot of value in these companies even doing it yet. But I do think that
as cybersecurity becomes a bigger AI safety threat, um, it's possible that they'll want them or as these
hackbot companies grow and have the money to potentially purchase the data set and they want to use those
as like rag where they pull in really good examples. That's exactly what I was going to say.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think, I think using it for rag has a lot more value than model fine tuning.
Yeah. Um, but, uh, yeah, I mean, I want to echo, I have talked to, um, at least hacker one in bug crowd.
Um, uh, so yeah, I think it's important to note, uh, but yeah, I think you hit the nail on the head where I think rag is a lot more important part of this.
Uh, so I think converting all of those into embeddings will at some point be, uh, necessary. And I think it, I think it's really interesting that like what, what you said of maybe at some point these companies say, uh, they're not going to be a lot of money. And I think it's really interesting that like what, what you said of maybe at some point these companies say, uh, they're not going to be a lot of money. And I think it's really interesting that like what, what you said of maybe at some point these companies say, uh, they're not going to be a lot of money. And I think it's really interesting that like what, what you said of maybe at some point these companies say, uh,
Hey, Justin, you have, you know, 2000 submissions here. We'd like to rag this. Here's 250 grand. And I'm like, Hmm. Yeah.
Okay.
Why wouldn't you in my opinion?
Yeah.
It's basically getting more value out of the, um, value you've already added, or it's like more value out of the work you've already put in.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, it's going to cost them a shit ton of money to buy that data and who knows, maybe they'll, they'll steal it from us. Like you said, you know, but I think that, um, right now,
that is not happening. So yeah, yeah, it would be interesting if there are any lawyers or smart people out there to know, uh, what kind of, um, what kind of rights or what kind of things we could do to protect ourselves in that regard. If it were to ever happen, like, I would love to know kind of what the recourse is, if it were to occur.
Cause I think right now we're kind of as a society trying to figure out what that looks like in the form of intellectual property of writing in that goes into these models and definitely the art community is trying to figure out what it looks like.
Like, I don't know if you saw it, Disney just sued mid journey for training on their stuff or something. And so it's going to be interesting to see how all this shakes out. And I think it'd be nice to know what our kind of, um, recourse.
It's going to set precedent for hackers for sure. Yeah. Um, all right. Last one that I had was once again, Jorian popping out some crazy stuff.
I, I, I tell you just tweets out and says, Hey, I'm not sure you guys know about the debug function in, uh, Chrome's, uh, dev tools.
And when I first read that, I was like, yeah, I know about the debug function. Like, of course I know about the debug function, but I did not know about the debug function.
Um, so listen up for a sec. If you, if you do client side hacking, um, essentially what he is saying here is that, uh, this, this function debug, uh, in Chrome,
which is different, not to be confused with the debugger directive in Chrome, um, actually allows you to kind of do almost dumb logger plus plus like hooking or like proxy,
like hooking where you can specify a specific prototype function. In this example, he specifies dom parser dot prototype dot parse from string,
something that's used to obviously parse, uh, HTML and convert it into a dom. Um, and then triggers a break point on that specific function.
Uh, and that was not something that I was familiar with.
And I think is really helpful for that quick and dirty.
I hate, I hate setting break points.
I still don't understand it to be totally honest.
And so I think this is going to be something I could potentially use to like get quick and
dirty break points without having to like, right click, set it.
Oh my gosh.
And doesn't it sometimes go away?
Like, nah, you can lose break points so easily.
I mean, it really, it depends on the way that the site is structuring their JS files.
And it's a massive pain in the butt when like, um, the name of JS files is like changing every time you refresh and you're like, oh, I can't set it.
Well, no, I mean, sometimes though, like, even if you set it and it's not doing that, if you accidentally click it to delete it, right?
Like if you click it, it's gone, right?
You can't recover it.
Yeah.
Sometimes.
And, and there's also quirks of like, oh, I disabled this break point, but it's still triggering and just dev tools for being one of the like, very essential tools is a little bit buggy.
I have a sec.
Yeah.
Um, uh, so anyway, this is another cool, cool piece.
And then one of the people from, um, uh, the comments section, uh, says that there's a, a writeup, uh, by, uh, bentowski, which is an amazing, uh, researcher
at Google zero day project, um, sorry.
He sort of covers this a little bit more, uh, specifically talking about how the debug directive back in the day, uh, was shared by, by the process, not by the, the origin.
So that you could set a debug directive on one on like, you know, blah, blah, blah.google.com.
And it would allow you to get XSS on www.google.com, email@google.com, all of these other things, if it was, you know, input directly into the dev console.
Yeah.
Um, which, you know, is not the most impactful.
Vulnerability, but is something that is not what I would have expected and would potentially have caused even an advanced user.
Right.
Of, of dev tools and of, uh, you know, Chrome to have some unintended consequences.
Yeah.
Uh, so definitely interesting reads both on this and just knowing how the debug function was.
Before you stop sharing, what is the dollar value there on tweets?
Is that, are the, are you in like a beta group, a beta test for showing how much money is from each impression?
I don't have that this right here.
Yeah.
I think maybe this is a Chrome extension or something like that, that like, you know, calculates the number of views by the average, uh, like payout on Twitter or something.
That's cool.
So I didn't know you had it's, it's interesting.
You can just be like, okay, you know, this tweet got 2,767 views and it's worth seven cents.
Right.
You know, if you're a, if you're a, uh, uh, uh, uh, monetized, um, sure person.
So anyway, definitely cool.
And then I kind of went a little bit deeper on this, uh, just cause I was mad that I didn't know about this and I was like, where are the docs for this?
And the docs are like super hard to find, uh, for this.
And I did track down some of them, which is just like a, essentially a blog post from developer.chrome.com sort of explaining how it works.
Um, and you can see, you know, that a function is being passed directly into the debug function, uh, here, but it's kind of hard to actually like pull up the docs on how exactly this works.
But I have seen, um, other places where it's used and there's like a condition being passed in as like the second parameter, but at least the first parameter is certain.
And that is a reference to a specific function or prototype where you want to cause a breakpoint to occur.
So definitely good to know about.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Well, I don't have anything else.
I, you know, I think we pulled out, uh, two pretty neat things to talk about on a future episode or maybe it's a bonus episode or something.
So we can do that.
But yeah, yeah, let's do it.
Let's call it a wrap for today.
Yeah.
Cool.
Thank you guys for sticking with us.
Peace.
Bye.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for watching to the end.
Y'all, if you want more critical thinking content, uh, or if you want to support the show, head over to ctbb.show/discord.
You can hop in the community.
There's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of the masterclasses, hack alongs, exclusive content, and a full-time hunters guild.
If you're a full-time hunter, it's a great time.
Trust me.
I'll see you there.
you